I WILL BE HONEST WITH YOU GUYS.
WE DON'T REALLY CARE WHAT
ANYBODY ELSE SAID IN THE DEBATE,
RIGHT?  LET'S GET TO OUR STAR.
YOU CALL WOMEN YOU DON'T LIKE
FAT PIGS, DOGS, SLOBS AND
DISGUSTING ANIMALS.
YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNT.
>> ONLY ROSIE O'DONNELL.
>> WELL I WILL TELL YOU WHAT,
WITH HILLARY CLINTON I SAID BE
AT MY WEDDING AND SHE CAME TO MY
WEDDING.
I DON'T MIND HAVING A BIG
BEAUTIFUL DOOR ON THAT WALL SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY LEGALLY.
>> Larry: AND OF COURSE ABOVE
THAT DOOR IT SAYS DONALD TRUMP
PRESENTS AMERICA, SOMEBODY'S
DOING THE RAPING.
DONALD TRUMP DOOR.
NOW, 24 MILLION PEOPLE TUNED IN
TO THIS DEBATE.
AND LET'S BE HONEST.
MOST PEOPLE TUNED IN TO SEE
DONALD TRUMP BE ALL TRUMPY,
RIGHT?  I MEAN IT'S LIKE GOD
BESTOWED US WITH THIS MOST
FANTASTIC TROLL TO GILL THE DOG
DAYS OF SUMMER WITH GLORIOUS
ENTERTAINMENT.
IN FACT, HE EVEN LOOKS LIKE A
TROLL DOLL.
LOOK AT HIS HAIR.
ALL RIGHT?  DOESN'T HE?  LOOK.
I HAVE ONE RIGHT HERE.
SEE, LOOK.
DOESN'T IT LOOK LIKE A TROLL?
>> I AM THE MOST ENTERTAINING
MOST LOVEABLE TROLL EVER.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
AND LIKE THE REST OF US, THE
MEDIA DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION TO
ANYTHING ELSE IN THE DEBATE
BESIDES TRUMP.
AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES THEY FOCUSED ON WAS
TRUMP'S ANGER AT WHAT HE
PERCEIVED AS BEING TREATED
UNFAIRLY, BY NONE OTHER THAN
FOX'S MEGYN KELLY.
YOU ONCE TOLD A CONTESTANT ON
CELEB APPRENTICE IT WOULD BE A
PRETTY PICTURE TO SEE HER ON HER
KNEES.
DOES THAT SOUND TO YOU LIKE THE
TEMPERAMENT OF A MAN WE SHOULD
ELECT AS PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK THE BIG PROBLEM THIS
COUNTRY HAS IS BEING POLITICALLY
CORRECT.
AND, HONESTLY, MEGAN, IF YOU
DON'T LIKE IT, I AM SORRY.
I HAVE BEEN VERY NICE TO YOU,
ALTHOUGH I COULD PROBABLY MAYBE
NOT BE, BASED ON THE WAY YOU
HAVE TOO TREATED ME, BUT I
WOULDN'T DO THAT.
>> Larry: SO HIS RESPONSE TO
BEING ACCUSED OF TREATING WOMEN
POORLY ON TELEVISION IS A THINLY
VEILED THREAT TO A WOMAN ON
TELEVISION?
>> IN FRONT OF 24 MILLION
PEOPLE:I KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I GET IT.
OF COURSE, HE TALKED TO DON
LEMON THE NEXT DAY AND PRETTY
MUCH RIPPED THE VEIL RIGHT OFF.
>> YOU COULD SEE THERE WAS BLOOD
COMING OUT OF HER EYES, BLOOD
COMING OUT OF HER, WHEREVER.
>> Larry: HER WHEREVER?
WHATEVER COULD YOU BE TALKING
ABOUT?  ARE YOU TRYING TO
INSINUATE THAT MEGYN KELLY'S
"AUNT FLOW" WAS IN TOWN?  HMM?
AND THAT'S WHY SHE WAS BEING SO
MEAN TO YOU?  SO HERE WAS
TRUMP'S EXPLANATION.
>> I SAID HER BLOOD WAS WHEREVER
BECAUSE I WANTED TO FINISH THE
SENTENCE BECAUSE I WANTED TO GET
OFF THE WHOLE THING AND GET BACK
ON TO THE SUBJECT OF JOBS OR
WHATEVER I WAS GOING TO SAY
THOSE AND/OR, NOSE AND/OR EARS
BECAUSE THAT IS A VERY COMMON
STATEMENT.
BLOOD POURING OUT OF SOMEBODY'S
NOSE.
>> I MEAN, EVEN DICK CHENEY
WOULD CLASSIFY THAT EXPLANATION
AS TORTURED.
SINCE WHEN IS SHE HAD BLOOD
COMING OUT OF HER EYES, NOSE AND
EARS A COMMON EXPRESSION?  I
HAVE BEEN WATCHING WHEEL OF
FORTUNE FOR 30 YEARS AND I HAVE
NEVER SEEN THAT.
NEVER.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN THAT, OKAY?
>> I ALSO DON'T BUY TRUMP SAYING
HE WAS IN A RUSH TO GET THE
CONVERSATION ON TO JOBS, AND
THAT'S WHY HE SAID, WHEREVER.
HOW IS SAYING WHEREVER FASTER
THAN SAYING NOSE?
>> WHEREVER IS TWICE AS LONG AS
NOSE, MORE THAN DOUBLE IF YOU
THROW IN THE EXTRA E LIKE I
ALWAYS DO.
>> IT WOULD BE UNFAIR OF ME TO
AY DONALD TRUMP IS LYING, OKAY?
HERE IS WHAT I BELIEVE ABOUT
TRUMP.
I BELIEVE TRUMP IS THE ONLY
PERSON WHO FULLY BELIEVES THINGS
AFTER HE SAYS THEM.
ALL RIGHT?  I MEAN, I AM WORTH
$10 BILLION, YOU ARE WORTH 4.
>> I SAID TEN, SO THAT'S WHAT I
BELIEVE.
ALL RIGHT?  HE SAYS, THEREFORE
IT IS.
RIGHT?  FOR EXAMPLE, THE FALLOUT
FROM MEGYN KELLY'S MENSTRUATION
GATE WAS IMMEDIATE.
RED STATE EDITOR ERICK ERICKSON
DISINVITED TRUMP FROM THE RED
STATE GATHERING IN ATLANTA ON
SATURDAY.
TRUMP'S RESPONSE?
>> FRANKLY, I DIDN'T WANT TO DO
HIS EVENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LARRY.
I DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT.
IT WAS MY PREDECISION THAT THEY
FULFILLED.
HE DID THE SAME THING WHEN NEIL
YOUNG TOLD HIM TO STOP USING HIS
SONG AT EVENTS.
>> I DON'T EVEN LIKE THAT SONG
THAT MUCH.
>> YEP, THAT WAS A HORRIBLE SONG
I POST HATED.
YOU KNOW WHO TRUMP SOUNDS LIKE?
>> I MEANT TO DO THAT.
>> Larry: OF COURSE, LARRY, IT
ONLY MAKES SENSE.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THE, AND THE CRAZIEST PART OF IT
IS, WITH ALL OF THIS NONSENSE
YOU WOULD THINK TRUMP IS
SLIPPING IN THE POLLS, BUT NO.
>> DESPITE THE CONTROVERSY AND
HEADLINES A NEW POLL FINDS
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL ON TOP
WITH REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
NBC NEWS SURVEY MONKEY POLL FROM
FRIDAY AND SATURDAY SHOWS TRUMP
23 PERCENT, TEN POINTS AHEAD OF
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
>> Larry: I FIND IT RICHLY
IRONIC IT IS SURVEY MONKEY WHO
FINDS TRUMP ON TOP OF THE POLLS.
IN FACT, WE ACTUALLY HAVE SURVEY
MONKEY LIVE VIA SATELLITE.
SURVEY MONKEY, HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT TRUMP SURGING IN THE
POLLS?
>> SURVEY MONKEY, I THINK WE
LOST THE MONKEY FEED.
>> LET ME JUST SUM UP WHAT WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH IN THE LAST
MONTH AND A HALF, IF I MAY.
OKAY.
SO FAR, TRUMP HAS CALLED
MEXICANS RAPISTS AND ATTACKED
ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST BELOVED
POWS AND GAME OUT A SITTING
SENATOR'S PHONE NUMBER OUT OF
SPITE.
AND NOW HE BASICALLY BLAMED A
WOMAN'S TOUGH QUESTIONING ON HER
PERIOD.
AND HIS POLLS JUST GO HIGHER AND
HIGHER AND HIGHER.
I KNOW LAST MONTH THE POLLS
SEEMED IRONIC, RIGHT?  WE WERE
ALL DOING A JOKE, WE WERE ALL
LAUGHING, HA, HA.
TRUMP IS FUNNY, MAN.
HE IS FUNNY.
HE IS GOING TO BE DONE IN A
WEEK, RIGHT?  AMERICA, I AM
TALKING TO YOU DIRECTLY.
STOP IT!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: STOP IT.
AMERICA, LISTEN TO ME, STOP IT.
>> THIS IS THE CLASSIEST MOST --
>> HUH-UH.
STOP IT.